Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
February 11th,
2019.
What is going on with you?
How are you?
Um,
I am actually recording part of this anyways,
I'll rerecording here Saturday night cause I'm out here tour and doing a little
bit of stand up and just when I have to fly on Sunday and then I got a fucking
bunch of Shit I have to do Monday.
I gotta I gotta do this as spurts.
Okay.
They got to do a couple of rounds here.
You know,
it's weird.
I've been walking around today all by myself,
all by my lonesome and uh,
for some reason I don't know why this fucking melody with the wrong lyrics has
been stuck in my head.
I just been walking around going Sherry's berries.
Why your buggin?
Okay.
Makes no fucking sense whatsoever.
I never had a song.
I always had a song from me undies be undies.
So Sherry's berries
keeps that they might have advertised,
advertise this can,
we gave no idea.
I'm doing this so early,
I don't even have the advertising yet.
You understand?
You understand how dangerous a podcast this is right now?
Um,
any ways,
any way,
I guess,
as I've been told I'm supposed to say and said.
Anyways,
anyway,
I'm fucking,
uh,
I did my first stand up road gig and since I came back from Europe,
ended the acting Gig and I walked out on stage,
got on the fucking bicycle and it was a,
it was all right.
Everything went great.
I want to thank everybody came out to the Borgata in Atlantic city.
I had a great fucking time.
And uh,
now I'm sort of barnstorming around just doing some like,
you know,
clubs and local areas and shit just still in the hour and trying to figure out
how I'm going to put this fucking thing together.
A widdle,
some shit down,
get in,
get out,
tape this fucking thing and then move on to my next hour.
My favorite fucking thing to do,
my favorite fucking thing to do is,
is the,
is the day after the special when all that material is flushed down the fucking
toilet and I get to start over again.
No fucking pressure.
You know the precious to special.
Once you get the special done,
you know,
if you like me,
you're going to continue to like fuck up in life.
So the material is going to come,
you know,
speaking of fucking up,
I was staying in this hotel about a week ago.
I forgot to tell you the story.
So fucking,
I swear to God like the level
okay
of like hostile
that corporations have got to as far as just complete lack of customer service.
He can't get anybody on the fucking phone.
Total skeleton crew go fuck yourself.
The the,
the way this,
this shit is now.
You know what I mean?
Like if you have a problem with you fucking iPhone,
who the hell are you going to call?
How the fuck you going to get anybody on the phone
or at least to somebody in front of them this fucking hemisphere,
you can't do it right.
So last couple of hotels I stay in,
right?
I go to call room service.
How long should that take?
Two,
three fucking rings.
Worst case scenario,
they usually have an outgoing message going like,
hey,
if we reached his message,
just leave your room number and we will,
uh,
we'll call you right back and we'll figure out what,
what,
whatever you want.
Right?
So a fucking call this the Goddamn thing rings three times.
Puts me on hold.
I put it on speaker.
I'm sitting there for like 15 fucking minutes.
So I hang up like,
all right,
so I fucking called the front desk and I was like,
yeah,
Hey,
I'm trying to order the Reuben,
the Reuben Sandwich there,
right?
I can't get through and nobody's picking up.
The lady at the front desk is like,
oh,
that's strange.
Here,
let me,
I'll put you right through.
Puts me through to the same extension on,
back on hold again,
listening to the same fucking music.
Sit there again for another 10 minutes now about 25 minutes and just trying to
order a fucking sandwich.
All right,
so then I go,
I fucked this.
I go to the next phone.
I called customer service is a customer service button.
So many picks up after three rings.
I tell him what the fucking problem is.
He said,
oh my God,
it's terrible.
I'm so sorry,
Mr. Burn.
Uh,
you know,
I'll,
I'll let me,
let,
let me get you through.
I'll stay on with you.
Right.
Same fucking extension.
Same fucking on hold music.
And I'm sitting there for like 15 seconds and I'm like,
wait.
I'm like,
Dude,
you still there?
He wasn't there,
so I fucking call back customer service again.
Somebody else picks up.
Yeah,
I see.
I tell the whole fucking story.
They just told you,
it's like the nighttime.
I'm telling this story,
I feel front desk to fucking cut third time.
Right.
And as I'm telling it,
she goes,
eat in,
stay on with you.
And I'm like,
no.
Like is that normal behavior?
She goes,
I'm sorry.
All right,
let me get you through.
And she finally gets me through.
Okay,
so room service.
It rings in the guy on the other end picks up room service and just goes,
hello?
I'm like,
yeah.
Ah,
is this rum service?
He's like,
yeah,
unlike a,
I'd like to order some food to the room.
It's like super awkward.
And he goes,
all right.
I go,
okay,
can I get that Reuben Sandwich?
He's like,
Yup.
I go,
all right,
can I get a side salad?
Yeah,
instead of the fries,
is it all right if I get a salad instead of the fries?
And he goes,
no
flat out says no,
no.
What am I going to do?
Complain to him.
He's got my food,
he's got me by the balls.
So I was like,
okay,
I,
you know,
I guess I'm eating fries.
He's like,
well what do you,
what do you want to drink?
I just go,
let me get a water with ice.
Okay.
See it goes all right.
So you know,
get in the room number and I fucking hang up.
Yeah.
And then I just sit there,
walk around with fucking hotel room,
muttering to myself.
God,
it literally took me a fucking half hour
to get through to somebody they could get me to somebody to order a fucking
sandwich to my room.
Yeah.
And then when I asked,
you know,
have it your way,
Burger King,
he basically was like,
yeah,
no,
go.
Fuck.
He's like,
I was his kid.
Daddy.
Can we get some ice cream now?
All right.
I guess you're taller than me and you're driving and you're paying for
everything.
So I guess what you say goes,
this guy's fucking talking to me like that.
So now I'm in another hotel
and uh,
I wanted to find out,
I don't know what,
there was a vending machine on this fucking floor and I'm trying to fund the,
there's no button on the phone that says front desk.
Yeah.
And this is feeling like a trend where I've noticed,
you know,
you go into your room,
if there's no menu,
you call him up.
If he can get somebody on the phone,
where's the menu?
They say it's on your TV.
And then you go on the TV and you got to use,
figure out your fucking remote control.
It's all on you.
You have to figure it out.
Okay.
Right.
And you've got to figure this shit out and then order it without talking to
anybody.
Okay.
MMM.
Like how far are they going to take this?
I feel like in the future,
like you're going to be like,
especially in this country with the fucking healthcare,
you're going to be like Diana's something and it's going to be up to you to
figure out like how to get ahold of somebody
and I don't know what,
you know if,
yeah.
Yeah.
Hey,
uh,
I got stabbed in the abdomen.
Okay.
Yeah,
I was wondering if I could get some,
uh,
room servers if you could like drive an ambulance over here.
Maybe like pick me up.
I,
yeah.
Can you,
uh,
you know,
maybe bring like some bandages and stuff?
No,
I,
well it was the ambulance going to show up?
Yeah,
that right.
It's going to be like,
like that level is shit.
I Dunno.
Okay.
My fucking pet pee though is people that hate their fucking job,
you know what I mean?
And then they take it out on you.
It's like,
dude,
it's not my fucking fault.
You work here.
Okay.
You don't like the job?
Quit.
I had shit jobs and I fucking,
I destroyed.
Okay.
You know the fuck are you doing?
You're going to try,
when you get your dream job,
go fuck yourself.
You're going to suck.
Okay.
The whole to Oh man.
Oh I got another good one.
I hope I'm,
I'm assuming you enjoyed that story is another travel story for you.
So I'm on my way to Atlantic city.
Right.
Okay.
And I uh,
I get on the plane and I'm sitting there and I just,
as I'm sitting there,
I'm looking down.
I Dunno what the fuck I'm doing.
Reading a magazine is some shit.
Yeah.
And uh,
I was reading rolling stone.
Hey,
this guy going bill burr.
Bill.
Hey Bill.
Bill Burn and look up.
I see it's this comic.
I know my God.
Shit.
Hey,
how you doing?
He's like,
you work in in Philly.
I was like,
no,
I'm landing there and I'm going to fucking drive over to Atlantic city.
He goes,
oh cool.
I'll talk to you when we get off right side and seen him in awhile.
I'm not gonna name any names here cause I don't want to get anybody in fucking
trouble.
Right?
So we get off the fucking get off the plane.
All right,
take a leak and come out.
He's fucking Stan.
Hey,
what's going on?
So we start shooting the shit and we're walking.
Okay.
And we get to the uh,
okay.
You know the moving sidewalk.
We hadn't seen each other a little bit.
We were standing side by side,
but you're not supposed to cause it's walk or stand to this guy as he's walking
up,
it's going,
excuse me,
excuse me.
Like he only had to say it once and we immediately immediately got out of the
way and it comes huffin buys,
he walks by and then he points up at the sign that says walk or stand.
So I just was like,
I got hit buddy.
Relax.
Okay.
He's walking away.
He goes,
you relaxed.
I go,
you're the one pointed at the sign.
He started talking more shit.
And I go,
Oh yeah,
I get it.
Yeah,
you got your ear buds in your important,
right.
So he starts giving me shit and I just started saying it turn around every now
and then I get a little bit.
So you know,
cause he was listening to and I made him so mad.
He gave me the finger.
It was like the highlight of my fucking trip
that was already in a bad mood because the second we landed some cont like five
rows back immediately turned on the cell phone and had like a conversation at
the top of his lungs.
You know,
and I know there's something weird about this where in that story,
the middle story,
I was the con cause I was standing where you were supposed to be walking.
But the thing is the second the guy said,
excuse me,
I knew what I was doing wrong and I immediately got out of the fucking way.
I didn't act,
you know,
I immediately got out of the way.
This guy's still shaking his fucking head.
Ah.
I was just looking at the guy like who the fuck are you to behave like me in
that situation?
You know the nervous some people
who are you to walk by mad at me that I wasn't aware that you were trying.
This is the thing he really,
even in a fucking
hurry,
cause he had the time to argue with me and give me the finger.
He's just one of those fucking people that just has to walk fast,
um,
until they feel like they're getting somewhere.
I don't know.
By the way,
I've got to tell you something.
Those stupid little fucking little half a straws that people have hanging out of
their fucking ears.
It's just,
you know,
that's like the Bluetooth headphones.
I think I'm very soon people are going to get there.
That's going to become like,
remember like Bluetooth was cool for like a week evidently.
And then everybody just made fun of that stupid thing hanging out of your ear.
I really think that those,
whatever those things are called,
I have no idea.
It always looks like you have it like a little bit,
little straw hanging out of your fucking year.
Um,
I'm not a fan of those.
I've always been a fan of headphones.
I don't like,
my ears are fucked from playing drums and I don't like jam and shit into my ear.
Um,
I dunno.
Plus,
you know what,
if you ever gotten like bright light tank right there.
What if we got into a fight,
right?
Me and that guy and I fucking throw a hook and I punched him right in the year
and then that then goes into his ear,
you know,
and then for the rest of his life,
he's listening to fucking blondie or something in one of his ears.
They can't get it out of her punches.
His ear drum is,
and I get sued,
you know,
all because I wanted to say hello to a comic.
Okay.
Do you understand that people,
that's how quick it can happen.
That's how quickly you can lose your hearing.
MMM.
By the way,
you know what's really fucking underrated?
A Old Lady Card Games.
I sat down with a relative of mine this past week,
there was a deck of cards there.
Right.
I had like a little family reunion.
Yeah.
Dang right.
And uh,
one of my relatives,
she's a little bit older or whatever.
I was just like,
hey,
you want,
you want to play Gin rummy?
And she was like,
yeah,
she proceeded to kick my ass for like the next hour.
But we weren't on our smartphones,
weren't watching TV,
weren't doing anything.
We were just sitting there,
you know,
talking about the old days,
laughing,
having a good time,
giving each other shit,
trying to remember how to keep score
and um,
I dunno,
I,
I guy really got allows sitting there going like,
you know,
that's one of the coolest hangs I've had with this particular relative in a long
fucking time.
MMM.
I Dunno.
It made me kind of think like,
you know what,
I should,
I need to bring that into my life.
You know,
my kid is going to be hilarious.
She's going to be like totally have this time.
And then like know how to drive like
a Ford f 103 on the tree.
She's going to know how to play Old Lady Card Games.
I figured like I'll all this shit that's fucking good from back in the day,
at least what I consider I'm going to teach her how
to do,
um,
old school shit,
like knowing how to cook as opposed to just doing the Postmates Shit,
you know,
whether she wants to do it or whatever,
she'll know how to do it,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I dunno
and me immediately think like,
what if I just converted my entire garage into like a cigar bar and had friends
over for over.
We played cards.
I had a smokey eat or so we could smoke inside.
Then I'm like,
well,
I can't fucking do that because then I'll fucking die of throat and mouth cancer
because it'll just be too God damn fun.
You know what I mean?
It's weird.
It's a really weird thing being an adult,
you know?
And it's also even more weird figuring it out at 50.
MMM.
Does she have that thing?
When all of a sudden,
you know,
I guess you go away to college or you just move out and you're like,
okay,
my parents aren't here anymore.
Now I can do whatever the fuck I want and
you do whatever the fuck you want for a while and then you just start paying for
it.
And uh,
I've kind of been learning this really at my age,
there's nothing better than going to bed sober and having eight hours of
uninterrupted sleep.
If I do that
and wake up,
stretch and then go to the gym,
I feel like,
like 15 years younger than I said,
I feel like I'm in my thirties.
Like it's fucking ridiculous.
Now having said that,
I plan to go back to booze,
you know,
at some point.
But I just,
uh,
I got to get through taping my special and then there's an outside chance I have
another acting gig coming up and uh,
you know,
cause you never know.
Now Jesus Christ do you have no fucking idea.
You know,
you speak back in the day,
if you,
if you will,
on something this far into where I'm at with this deal.
You were in there,
but not nowadays.
You know,
one fucking tweet or somebody reads some shit from fucking,
you know,
somebody pulls out a yearbook from the 80s.
I mean,
you know,
you don't know what can happen.
You don't know what's in there.
You don't,
you don't know what the fuck other people have done.
And all it takes is one principle fucking person.
You know,
there's some fucking,
you know,
VHS tape of him kicking a pigeon in the fucking beacon and then the whole
fucking thing goes away.
So I don't know.
Um,
so anyways,
so there is a thing that I always like,
you know,
I've always wanted to go an entire calendar year,
January 1st through December 31st and not drink and just be like,
I didn't drink that year.
So I think,
uh,
I think this might be the year,
I don't know.
It's already cruising by.
I'm like fucking 11 weeks in already.
You know,
what's the point of stopping?
By the time I take my special,
that'd be another three weeks.
That's 14 weeks.
52 weeks in a year.
52 minus 14,
38 weeks to go.
Okay.
I'm not,
I'm going to,
I can't make it through that.
I think I can do it.
Um,
but anyways,
what the fuck else did I want to talk about?
I'm actually sitting here now,
late night,
just did a spot and uh,
um,
I'm watching showtime boxing.
You know,
it's weird.
I,
I didn't realize HBO,
like let go with a box box,
oops,
sorry.
Boxing after all of these years.
And then on top of that,
uh,
Jim Lampley is gone.
So they still got that Al Bernstein guy or whatever,
I don't know.
But they got all these new announcers and shit.
So it's a weird transition,
you know what I mean?
It's like when you're a kid,
like the voices of it is as big a part as,
as watching it.
So it just takes a while.
Like,
well,
I gotta be honest with you,
like this transition of,
um,
new announcers in the NFL really took me a while.
Um,
and that's why I'm loving Tony Romo cause he's like the greatest,
like,
like all my [inaudible] God,
this guy like Tony Roma's still in his thirties,
right?
Like this guy can announce for like another 30 fucking years in the level that
he knows the game is.
This is like,
it's a great thing,
you know,
cause Al Michaels,
I mean,
Al Michaels is good.
I'm glad to be what like in his seventies,
you know,
and uh,
okay.
Just those voices that I grew,
I,
I'm so old.
Like I remember the end of curt Gowdy.
Um,
there was,
uh,
pat Summerall and um,
John Madden for the longest time,
dawn crickey,
all of these guys and just their voices were just football.
Um,
I wish I could have,
I should have looked up some more of a,
uh,
well,
what's his face?
He just passed recently.
Can see his face.
He's the host a game show.
Oh my God,
I'm the fucking worst.
The fuck did I forget his name?
I Dunno.
Whatever.
These guys were all the voices of it.
So anyway,
so now I'm watching a box in here.
I'm like,
they join the boxing,
but I'm like these voices,
like who the fuck are these people talking?
Man?
It's just,
it's a weird thing.
It's like when your favorite bag,
it's like a new lead singer or something.
Right.
Okay.
So let's just say CDC,
somehow DC was able to do it.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about.
All I know is this right?
Is right around the time.
Okay.
When I would start doing advertising,
but I don't have any advertising yet.
So let's see,
what else did I want to talk about?
Maybe I'll,
I'll,
I'll record the advertising after.
Maybe I'll do something like that.
Oh,
I got one for you.
I'm watching the boxing by the way.
The boxing,
that's how old I am.
MMM.
I'm watching boxing in the,
uh,
okay.
You know what's funny is the UFC is so fucking destroyed.
This sport fucking destroyed this sport.
Well,
they were destroying themselves with the corruption in people ducking fights and
just bad decisions and all of that.
Basically throughout my whole fucking life.
Okay.
But they have so destroyed them,
but you know,
it's fun.
I shouldn't even bring this up or it's just funny to me.
Nobody's really paying attention to it.
So like when the ring girls get in the crowd,
there's still all these people going
when fucking whistle in and shit like a fucking bugs bunny cartoon.
They all you're doing is not barking like a dog and stomp on their foot on the
fucking floor.
You know what I mean?
But as I've always maintained,
like when it,
when it comes to this getting offended shit,
it has to be something big enough that they'll waste their time,
uh,
attaching their wagon.
Oh my God.
Is,
is that far?
Is is Larry Merchant gone?
Okay.
Larry Merchant,
I mean,
Jesus Christ that he,
that guy is like a cunt cunt.
MMM.
He,
he,
there was just certain fighters you could tell he just fucking hated them,
you know?
And he would never say anything positive.
And then he'd go in the ring and start talking tough.
Like he was going to fucking do something.
MMM Bye.
[inaudible],
you know,
he had that get off my lawn vibe.
Um,
but anyways,
I was looking at my,
uh,
my travel schedule for that run that I have that starts in Iceland and ends in
Israel.
Uh,
I have a day off
yeah.
Between wherever the fuck I end and then flying over to Israel and on that day
there's a moto GP race in Spain.
But I just think it's going to be too much to try and get to,
but I really was going to try to catch a fucking racist shit.
I was going to try to go to Austin,
but um,
my schedules not working out,
but I'm so fucking ridiculously excited for Formula One in Moto GP to start back
up again.
This is what gets me through.
It's,
you know,
you got the dog days of summer with baseball.
This is like the dog days before.
I guess it's really just February now because march madness is next month.
Okay.
You know,
football's fucking over so much madness is next month.
But basketball and hockey,
if it doesn't really start fucking mattering until like,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
the beginning of April,
you figuring out who's going to be what seed or whatever,
uh,
speaking in which congratulations to the Lakers and the last second shot beat my
fucking Boston Celtics.
Um,
I dunno what's going on with the Celtics.
I got the stupid fucking,
what they call it,
the hardwood classic package.
And I,
I've watched like three Bruins games this year and like half a Celtics game over
Christmas.
I've just been so goddamn busy.
It's killing me.
I don't know what's going on.
All I know is we have all this talent on the Celtics and I don't know if they're
underachieving or what,
but like I said,
I was doing that acting Gig last week and one of the guys on the set today,
what's up with Kyrie?
Is he going to go to la?
Um,
so just the fact that he was asking that made me,
uh,
made me a little bit nervous.
Um,
hey,
by the way,
I'm watching this for this Davis Ruiz fight.
So I hopped up.
That's how you say his fucking name.
And uh,
for half a second,
I thought it was in Los Angeles,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
I could have fucking gone to that.
But it's in Carson city,
Nevada.
And I was just thinking that's one of the few cities I've never been to.
Okay.
You know,
I've been to,
I've been all the A's,
all the B's in most of the CS sealevel cities.
Not saying that you city sucks,
it's just,
you know,
there's no professional sports team there.
You know,
there's no traffic is a bit of a math problem.
you know the characteristics of the sea city.
You're downtown still.
You can still,
if you squint your eyes,
you're surprised like coal younger and Jesse James Aren't walking up the street.
It's still has that,
you know,
wild west look about it.
At least it does out here.
Carson city actually that is the capital of Nevada and I've never fucking been
there.
A lot of people,
if you were to ask them,
hey man,
like what's the Capitol in Nevada?
They would be like,
well,
I would have to say that's Los Vegas.
And if you said no,
they'd be like,
okay,
a fucking Reno.
And you'd be like,
all right,
there's no reason that swear at me.
But no,
it's not reno.
Then they might even guest Loughlin before they would get,
I don't even know where the fuck it is.
Where the,
Oh,
Carson city.
it's just south.
Just south of Reno.
I Love Reno.
I fucking love ring.
Oh,
and there's Lake Tahoe maybe.
I have been,
I've been to Lake Tahoe.
Jesus Christ said,
I just like pass right through Carson city.
That even fucking realize it.
How the fuck did Carson city ended up being the capital?
This has gotta be like some sort of gold rush,
cowboy shit.
By the way,
there's a movie out called the man who killed Hitler and then the big foot
starring Sam Elliot.
All right.
If you don't fucking immediately try and find out how you can watch that movie.
You are no friend of mine.
It's about a guy,
you know the character.
He's the guy that found Hitler and killed them in World War II and now they're
pulling him out of retirement because the big foot,
not big four,
the big foot,
just like I'm watching the boxing.
All right?
He has to go to Canada and kill the big foot because evidently big foot is
walking around carrying some sort of plague that could wipe out human beings.
So,
and evidently,
I guess big foot is the Hitler of like,
uh,
abominable snowman.
How do you say that?
Fucking,
I don't know.
Okay.
Like what,
what I dunno of Apes,
what fucking world does,
I mean,
look this up right now,
this is,
this is why the feds will never come and pick me up.
They'll never worry.
No matter how much conspiracy theory I say that I might be right about when they
just check my Google searches here.
Okay.
They'll just be like,
all right,
this guy is not a threat because of this Google search right now,
what kind of animal
is,
somebody said big bird.
Big Foot.
Okay.
I wonder if I'm the first one to ever search that.
What kind of animal,
big foot or Scotch swatch are said to be Harry Upright walking.
Okay.
Is it from any sort of family?
You know,
it's,
it's like an eight fucked Bill Walton,
as far as I can tell in North American folklore,
bigfoot or Sasquatch are said to be Harry Upright walking ape like creatures
that dwell in the wilderness and leave footprints.
That's the funny thing about big foot.
What,
what the fuck is the thing ever really done?
Yeah.
It walks around.
Okay.
You know,
a Sasquatch.
You gotta leave your footprints all over the fucking place.
You know,
it's always running away.
It hasn't really done anything.
That's why I love this movie.
They've somehow found a reason
for man to finally find big foot and then kill the fucking thing.
All right.
If I was writing that screenplay,
okay.
Big Foot,
having that fucking,
you know,
carrying the plague.
Um,
in the end you would find out that it was all bullshit,
you know?
Then it,
it,
it wasn't really doing anything.
It just,
where it was walking around,
there was a lot of oil underneath the land where it was walking around.
So
the government then demonize big foot and said that it could take down this
entire first world nation because it's walking around with the fucking was
scarlet fever.
First of all,
nobody's ever seen big foot.
They don't know where the fuck are thing is.
There's never really been a good picture of the God damn thing yet somehow they
know it has the fucking plague.
All I know is Sam in it and I'm going to fucking watch that movie.
Um,
okay.
Is it in theaters?
You know something.
Can you fuck him?
I still can't believe aqua man made all that money,
mate.
I mean,
God,
I mean happy it did.
I'm happy some movies making some fucking money.
May 250 fucking million dollars.
I can't believe people saw that fucking movie.
Aqua man.
He's a superhero in the ocean.
A fish don't commit crimes.
I know you want to go see it.
Yeah,
I didn't see that movie.
What I would do is if I was right now Aquaman,
Aquaman is fucking pissed off because of that swirl.
A trash out in the fucking Pacific Ocean.
And he's fine because he's not really a person.
Is it?
Right.
That should be my next Google search.
What kind of fish is Aquaman?
What did Aquaman do you know what he is?
Some pirate fucked a mermaid.
Okay.
And that's,
and then the mermaid gave birth to Aquaman.
Alright.
Aqua man grew up without a dad.
It's probably a viking with this blonde hair.
He used to have blond hair anyways.
I don't know.
When I was a kid,
he had blonde hair and an orange shirt,
you know,
now he looks like the fucking undertaker.
Anyways,
undertakers nephew.
So anyways,
I was writing that fucking movie.
Alright.
Some Viking bagged a mermaid whose kid knew historically speaking,
probably raped her,
right?
So he's the rate baby of a Viking and a mermaid.
All right?
So his dad's not around and he's a rapist.
So there's no reason to look that guy up.
Plus he's on land and he has gills.
It can fucking breathe underwater.
And he sort of speaks through like waves.
So I mean
it's bad enough.
You've got to try to fucking,
you know,
call up a rapist on father's day now.
I mean you don't really speak,
so how can you communicate with them?
And then the mom,
you know,
sorta shuns him because of obviously how she got pregnant.
So he is just sort of fucking,
you know,
he has issues with his mom.
Definitely doesn't like his dad and his dad's really the only land dweller that
he knows.
So he's just like,
you know what?
Fuck this man.
I don't need anybody.
I'm just going to hang in the ocean with my fish friend.
Right.
Cause cause you know,
they don't fucking judge them or anything.
They take them in like,
you know,
like the wolf's with the babies that get left out in the woods.
All right,
just bear with me.
I'm going
to get somewhere with this.
So then the fucking guy,
you know,
as he gets older and older and older,
right?
They just stay,
just sitting there.
Uh,
all this trash keeps getting dumped in the ocean and finally he can't fucking
take it anymore.
And it gave,
just goes on land and he starts fucking taking people out like Charles Bronson
and Deathwish.
All right,
okay.
You know,
and like death wish it starts with a rape.
All right?
Put in this one.
A,
he's doing it for the environment and the first people he kills are hoarders.
Well,
I guess hoarders he'd likes cause they don't pull it,
throw it in the ocean.
You know what I mean?
He'd go after all those people know,
you know,
it fucking kill,
kill those people that,
that uh,
made that TV show about being minimalists that encourage all these people after
they bought all this shit to just go down and dump it at goodwill and then
goodwill just throws it in the fucking ocean or whatever the fuck it is they do
with it.
You know what I mean?
Um,
man,
all the people I thought I thought he would kill when I really think about it.
When Kelly was thinking though,
people in storage wars,
he killed them.
He wouldn't,
those people take shit that usually get thrown out and they'd fucking buy it and
they find some stupid fucked up by it.
Okay.
I think he just hangs out at a goodwill and just as people show up at the
garbage bags of shit,
he's just fucking take some and before the cops can get there,
right?
The cops chase him back to the fucking ocean.
You know,
maybe it goes to that swirl of trash and he's just find shit and he just goes
through any fines,
addresses.
I don't fucking know.
I'll be honest with you.
I don't even know what I'm talking about at this point.
I'm just telling you how I would do movies that I never saw.
I don't know.
What the fuck did they do with aqua man?
And then they gave him that chicken of the sea fucking pitchfork.
I didn't understand it.
Is He mad that we're eating tuna?
We're killing all his friends.
You know,
if that's the case,
he should start in Japan.
They're the ones that's doing all the Sushi.
They started that shit.
Right.
See,
I'm trying to get it out of my country.
Um,
all right,
so they go,
no,
I don't know where to go from here because now I only have like a fucking half
hour left.
I still have to do advertising and reads.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
read your question.
So that's what I'll do on Monday.
I'll just bang out the last 25 minutes of this.
Um,
this has been the first half of the podcast,
the ramblings of a lonely man.
Okay.
Who was in a hotel room and he wants to call the front desk,
but there's no information on how exactly I'm supposed to fucking do that.
But it's a good thing because I was going to order food and I'm not fucking
hungry anymore.
All right.
I'm going to watch this God damn fight and through the magic of and time.
Uh,
there'll be no delay on your podcast.
Just know the next time I talk,
uh,
I don't know where it'll be Sunday or Monday.
I don't fucking know.
What do you give a shit?
Right?
Cause it's going to be a half a second delay for you.
And just like that,
now I'm in Los Angeles.
Isn't that amazing?
Isn't that amazing what an edit can do to you.
That was one second for me.
That was a fucking,
you know,
it's Monday morning.
Um,
I almost feel like I have to do the intro.
So much time has gone by,
by the way,
I believe the last thing I was talking about Saturday say deal.
Why don't you fucking come over on Saturday,
Saturday,
Saturday.
Say I'm not a card game that I played.
Okay.
Crazy eights or some people call it dirty eights not so just a great fucking
game.
And I
okay.
Suddenly realized,
You know,
cause I went over one of my relatives,
uh,
domiciles there and I'm just fucking
okay.
I was just walking around all wound up like I usually am brain going a mile a
minute.
Can't fucking shut it off,
you know?
Yeah.
The only thing that I've found that can shut it off is copious amounts of
alcohol or sitting down and smoking a cigar.
Neither of them are good for you,
but I found with cards,
if I just sit down,
there's something about shuffling the car's handling,
the cards gets rid of that energy.
And I fucking chill out.
And then amazingly enough,
when I play cards,
I have to learn how to control my emotions or else people know what's in my
hand.
I found it very therapeutic,
you know,
the TV wasn't on the entire time I was there and I didn't look at my smartphone
and my head felt clearer.
Okay.
So I think I learned,
so I think I'm already a scatterbrain
and uh,
all the TV screens and phone screens do not help.
Someone like that doesn't help someone like me is my brain's like,
oh,
what about this?
What about this?
While I fucking look that up?
Oh,
is that what that is?
what does this link to?
Oh,
what,
what does so and so looked like now that will surprise me,
you know?
And then I'm just fucking,
there goes two hours of my life and then I'm laying in bed and I can't fucking
get to sleep.
So,
okay.
I'm going to try to get my wife into playing cards,
although I don't think she's going to do it because she's inherently a chill
person.
And I'm worried that if she starts playing cards,
she might literally nod off and fall backwards out of the chair.
But anyways,
oh,
Billy freckles.
Oh,
79 days,
no fucking booze.
And I'm,
I've got to admit,
I am getting shit done.
I did a couple of things that I would never do.
I edited two episodes of,
uh,
efforts.
Her family went through the script and throwing in my punchlines did it on the
fucking plane in there is no way.
All right.
When it's not the off season,
if I'm playing,
if the season has started,
there is no fucking way I would have gotten half of that done.
I would have sat there on the plane,
I would have watched a movie,
I would have had one and I'd be like,
Hey,
I liked this failing.
Can we enhance it?
Yeah.
So
I dunno.
Do they have like binge drinker a AA meetings?
You know,
everybody there is just like board like,
yeah,
you know,
I can stop,
I don't need the fucking,
you know,
I dunno.
I just named me.
It's a place where they're playing cards or some shit.
Yeah,
Bill called the casino.
Um,
you don't,
and you don't have to drink.
You can make that choice for yourself.
You can be brave.
You can be a warrior,
can be all of these fucking things.
Um,
all right,
hang on a second.
Anyways,
I need to read some of the advertising here for this week here.
Oh,
you know what?
I was coming back from our New York City,
so I always get the New York Post.
That's my thing,
man.
I read the post and the Daily News,
but mostly the post cause I like the sports section better.
Um,
I uh,
you know,
I was reading this shit,
the Yankees like spring training started and it's so fucking funny,
like the Yankee Mindset,
which is totally George Steinbrenner,
where like we,
we haven't won a world series.
You know,
we lost to the red sox to the honeymoon is over and grab bar by rabbi.
There's always a,
there's always this threat,
you know,
with that whatever manager they have a whatever,
there's always this constant pressure that like they have to somehow do the
impossible,
which is to win the way they used to win.
Well,
actually they would accept the way they want in the late nineties,
but um,
I do respect that out of that franchise.
But it's also funny because it's an empty threat.
Like,
what are you gonna stop watching?
You know,
we all know we're not going to abandon our teams,
at least the real fans one.
All right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Legal Zoom.
If you're determined to start a business or secure your family's future in 2019,
it's easy to get distracted by hurdles that pop up along the way.
How many would it be?
Okay if we went out to here?
Whoa,
whoa.
That's right.
Whatever you just agreed to,
that's when you would have done your fucking will.
That's why legal zoom is here to help.
But their network of independent there gunslingers that wild man.
They're out there on their own,
licensed in all 50 states.
How the fuck do you do that?
You're going to take the bar exam 50 times.
Legal Zoom can help you navigate your legal needs.
We'll bill once you're a lawyer.
You nearly need to me to fill out an application.
Well,
but our bell,
they hired 50 lawyers.
Maybe they did that one from each state,
I dunno.
From wills and trusts to Llcs,
trademarks,
contract reviews and move our legal zoom has helped more than 4 million people.
Like you take care of their responsibilities and the best part is,
and you are responsible.
Okay.
Yeah.
Bring a life into this world.
God Damn it.
They need to get some cash.
When you fucking face planet of food court and you put that last piece of orange
chicken and your God Damn Pie hole.
And the best part is legal zoom is not a law firm.
So you won't get charged by the hour,
uh,
make this year,
the year you finally do the right thing for your family
or take the steps you need to take for your small business.
Legal Zoom is here to help so you can focus on what you need to do.
But what you do best make it make a difference in your life.
I hate when I just all of a sudden can't fucking read.
Slow down pill.
Make a difference in your life this year by visiting legal zoom.com now and for
special savings.
Be sure to enter Promo Code Bur bur are in the referral box at checkout legal
zoom where life meets legal.
That's legal zoom.com oh man.
You know why it went off the rails,
but I crushed it in the end.
It's the simply safe.
Are you simple and you want to be safe?
We have a solution for you.
So here's a timely stat stat for you.
I'm almost half of us make a new year,
new year's resolution every single year.
We've all made them and most of us probably broken them,
not me,
man.
I said I wasn't drinking this year.
I'm better than you happens to the best of us,
but one resolution worth sticking to this year,
keeping your home and family safe.
That's why I recommend simply safe home security.
Evidently according to the copy,
I didn't realize that I recommended it.
I thought I'd just read it because they gave me money over there.
Simply safe is a 24,
seven home security is 24,
seven home security with no contracts or catch catches.
They believe the safest place on earth should be your home.
So you feel protected every time you shut your door and leave for work or shut
your eyes at night.
I'll save this Ted Nugent feel at home.
You know,
he walks around with like a fucking gun strapped to each leg and a crossbow
around his fucking back.
More than three electric.
See,
somebody shoot me when I take a piss in my own half more than 3 million people
instead of leaves,
you know,
in his hat,
he probably has like wallpaper,
you know,
so it blends in with his house.
More than 3 million people already feel this way every day,
thanks to simply safe.
And they're not the only ones.
They're not the only wall hons with home security.
The folks at PC magazine named simply safe,
both editor's choice in reader's choice for 2018.
Well,
there you go.
There's a legit magazine,
PC magazine.
Um,
2000,
I'd never heard of it.
2019 feels like a good year to ask yourself,
is my home is safe?
As it could be any of you thinking,
well,
maybe this year or if you're thinking,
maybe this year,
uh,
maybe this is the year to change that.
Fuck.
Call to action.
Get simply safe and just get simply safe.
Just go to simply safe birth.com to get started.
That's simply safe bird.com to protect your home and family today.
Simply safe birth.com oh,
Jerry's berries.
Why your bug in,
uh,
talk about your plans for Valentine's Day this year.
What would you do if you weren't procrastinating?
I didn't procrastinate and had my wife reached out to somebody of influence and
they got us a reservation at a fucking restaurant that we wouldn't be able to
get into if I just called myself.
Yeah.
Do you know who I am?
I did a half hour comedy central once.
Hello.
Well going in Mcdonald's.
All right.
Um,
share a personal Valentine's Day story.
What are your must gives?
You got to get a Ricard.
Okay.
Uh,
you got to get her some flowers.
You got it.
You can't just give her the card and have something that some stranger rope.
Okay.
For whoever bought the card.
Yeah.
You have to add a paragraph of your own shit
and you have to write that paragraph out on something else,
so when you inevitably have a spelling error or run out of room or something
like that,
you don't do it on the card and then you painstakingly copying
over to the new card and then you hand it to your wife.
She reads it in three seconds it goes,
oh,
reaches over,
gives you a nice kiss and then looks over your shoulder to see if there's a
package in some sort of heart shape rapping to see if she got some shiny shit so
she can decide at what level she's going to fuck you that night she going to go
through the motions.
Is she going to give you the first three months of your relationship sex or is
she going to take it to another level?
It all depends on whether or not there's a tray of Sherry berries over your
shoulder.
When she goes to hug you.
I mean,
come on people.
Do I even need to read the copy after this?
I'll do it just as an exercise in trying to get better on how to re reading out
loud.
Okay.
Um,
never go wrong with the um,
with their signature dipped valentines strawberries dipped in milk,
dark or white chocolatey goodness for any discerning palate.
She'll fall in love with every bite.
Stop cheating on a top with decadent toppings.
Chocolate chips,
heart and glittery sprinkles.
Honey,
I have to admit I'm having an emotional affair.
Was Sherry's berries.
Always fresh,
always tasty,
always worth the wait,
perfect companion to a candle lit dinner,
a bouquet of flowers or a night on the town.
Valentine's made easy,
arrives fresh with 100% Sherry's berries.
Guarantee chips anywhere nationally.
Give sweet somethings to your long distance.
Love Valentine's Day is just a few days away.
Send her a Valentine's Day gift of her dreams at the price of your dreams.
Starting at just 1999 plus shipping and handling plus,
order now and make this Valentine's Day really special by getting double the
berries for just $10 more.
Go to Barry's dot Com B e r r,
I e s.com.
Click on the microphone and enter my code at checkout.
That's B e r r,
I e s.com.
Click the microphone and enter code burr order today.
Hey,
what do you do if your,
if your girlfriend,
you know it's getting a little hefty there.
You don't wanna get in chocolate covered strawberries.
Can you just get her the strawberries too?
They have an Ali card,
strawberry,
maybe a,
a uh,
a chocolate covered Brussel sprout a stamps.com stamps.com is the fastest and
more convenient way to get postage.
You want me hilarious as if your girlfriend got you Rogaine for fucking
Valentine's.
They simply use your computer to print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail,
anywhere you want to send.
And the mail carrier picks it up.
No more lugging the mail to the post office.
She now heavy envelopes are no more hassles man.
With stamps.com you get discounted postage rates that you can't even get at the
post office.
Not to mention it's a fraction of the cost of those expensive postage meters
and there's no equipment to lease and no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com anytime I sent out my posters,
I'm a fucking moron if I can do it.
I was,
oh can you?
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with the special offer
that includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital stakeout scale.
So start the new year off right.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top,
the homepage and type in burger that stamps.com enter burr are right now.
Let's get to,
let's fucking read them.
May Yo let's fucking read the mail.
All right,
from Reddit Los Angeles then and now follow up.
I love that someone gave me this here cause I'm going to go back to reading
books now.
Like I read a lot of them,
but like I really think that my brain does not do well.
Watching a bunch of shows in and screens and stuff.
I just,
I find I'm going to go,
I'm going to do some old people.
Shit,
we're going to play cards.
I'm going to complain to the local,
my local representative about the sidewalk having a crack in it or whatever the
fuck old people do,
but it ain't no whatever.
I'm going to read some books.
We'll see.
Um,
there are a lot of,
my,
my favorite things to do those with Reader's digest is to read the awful jokes
to my wife.
And I know that that's a Jim Norton bit back from the Opie and Anthony Show,
but I feel like if I do it in my bedroom,
I'm not stealing from him.
Maybe I'll give him credit next time.
He used to read the comics was one of my favorite bits that he would do.
Um,
then the local news,
the newspaper,
daily comic,
sorry.
There are a lot of books on Los Angeles history.
Okay.
Ah,
this person writes,
I find the whole,
the whole thing fascinating.
Why am I so much,
uh,
even thought it's history,
even though it even thought,
even though person wrote thought,
even though it's history isn't as long as Boston,
Philly and New York,
the whole thing is fascinating.
Um,
let me see.
They said I made an album,
uh,
on this go to the page.
I would like to see this.
Okay,
let's see.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Look at the old,
oh my goodness.
Look at these old houses.
Holy Shit.
They just knocked all of this shit down,
didn't they?
Okay.
Oh many times.
Must a plow at fucking over.
You know,
a lot of old houses.
They just had that creepy fucking look.
But these are incredible.
And you know what?
I just realized that you guys can't see him.
All right,
let's get back to whatever the fuck it was I was reading.
Um,
Ben highlights just how,
okay.
I'm at an album that highlights just how true bill's bulldoze everything is.
La destroyed an entire historic neighborhood downtown to force the poor from the
city center and build more economically viable skyscrapers.
One of the darkest blemishes and Ellie's history.
And that's not the,
that's not the whole knee wall on the amount of neighborhoods is destroyed and
people displaced due to freeway construction is astronomic and is estimated at
300,000 people were displaced between 1940 and 1974 the freeways,
which pretty much destroyed the history.
This historic city explains why La is more suburban,
uh,
than cities San Francisco.
Yeah.
It's fascinating how they do a lot of stuff.
You know,
there's eminent domain,
which means,
well,
we're building this freeway.
He can take this money for your house or we'll just fucking take it from you.
Um,
I try not to get too sad about it.
I just look at it like,
you know,
when those historic neighborhoods were being built,
there was native Americans crying going,
you know,
we used to fucking sit there and uh,
I dunno.
It's just getting a buffalo,
whatever the fuck it.
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck.
You know,
there's always going to be somebody that,
you know,
you know what used to be there,
so I don't know.
Get a deck of cards and shut off your fucking TV and maybe can have a nice 20
minutes to yourself.
All right.
Advice from Mormon at Byu.
Um,
hey there,
Billy nickname.
Uh,
last week in your podcast you read a letter from a Mormon attending Byu asking
for advice about leaving the church as a former Mormon.
That's a great former Mormon.
Hi,
I'm Mike Mormon.
I'm a former Mormon.
Keep it going for the former Mormon who also grew up in Utah.
I thought I could only offer a little advice for them.
I thought I could offer a little advice for them.
I also went through something similar when I was 19 I told my parents I wasn't
going to go on a mission,
which is a huge rite of passage in the Mormon religion.
Oh my God,
they must have been crushed and then you got to deal with upsetting the two
people that you want the most approval approval from.
They were really upset about it and it was hard for me to do,
but I couldn't lie to myself anymore and try to believe in what the church
teaches.
Not long after that,
I moved out of my parents' house and started attending the University of Utah in
Salt Lake City.
It seemed daunting at the time and I didn't know.
I didn't think I would be able to afford it,
but somehow is able to do it.
Good for you.
The hardest part about leaving the church is that all that the other members
will ask you a million questions about why you're leaving and they're always
trying to convince you to come back.
Obviously,
you can't shut out your family completely,
but if you don't believe in what the Church teaches,
then you're not doing yourself any favors by staying just because it's routine.
Take it from me.
I left the church a long time ago and I don't regret it.
The people I know who have regrets,
other ones I went to high school with,
stayed in the church,
went on missions,
got married in the temple and ended up leaving Mormonism.
Anyway,
uh,
they all say that they would do things differently if they had to do it over
again.
The Mormon church isn't going anywhere.
It will always be there.
If you eventually decided to go back,
decided to go back,
but you'll never get your time back if you decide to stay in the church and then
end up regretting it.
I hope this helps and I'm sure you'll meet people who feel the exact same way
you do.
I've met tons of them and they really helped me out anyways as always.
Thanks and go hug yourself.
Wow.
Yeah.
I imagine if you know,
if you looked for some sort of support group online,
you could probably find a way to do that and I like what he said.
The church is always going to be there.
You can always come back,
you know or you know.
Maybe you enjoy it as much as this guy does and you stay out.
There you go.
It's your life.
You choose.
All right.
Advice from Warman.
Here we go.
Here's another one,
dear Billy bow,
Look it up.
All right.
What was this Mormon football bag?
Let's see.
B.
A.
L.
Yeah,
Mormon word.
How many time bol.
Okay.
All right.
What the fuck is this?
This is some deep religious shit here.
Bible dictionary.
Okay.
B,
a l,
possessor lord the Sun God and the mail or
should narrative principle in nature.
He was worshiped with different ideas and rights in different places.
So it's a possessor Lord.
Yeah,
the fuck is a possessor.
Lord.
Is that a landlord for Jesus?
I don't,
I don't even know what that means to you.
This is why I,
why I just try to keep my life simple cause even if I don't know a word,
if I look it up,
I still don't know the word.
All I'm left with is more questions.
Just wanted to chime in on the advice that she gave that kid at Byu.
Okay,
good.
Cause I didn't think I gave him good advice.
I had no idea what I,
whatever.
I grew up Catholic on the east coast and converted to Mormonism when I was 18
then a year later I left my top 20 college to serve a mission in Las Vegas.
Okay.
You went to Las Vegas to try and convert people.
Jesus Christ.
You dove in with both feet.
Yeah.
Can I just talk to you for a second about Mormonism.
Okay.
Some guy sitting at a blackjack table,
he's on a roll or even worse.
He's fucking losing.
When I got back,
my school wouldn't take me.
I was in a music program for drums and hadn't practiced in two years.
So I had hoped to go to Byu for a year and build my chops back up before I could
get back into my original program.
Wait a minute.
What do you mean?
In what way would the fuck does your school not take you?
I was a grew up Catholic.
He converted Mormonism.
You left your top 20 college to serve a mission in Las Vegas?
When I got back,
my school wouldn't take me.
Yeah.
Oh.
So I had to go to Byu,
uh,
for a year and build my chops back up before I could get back into my original
program.
Ah,
cause you haven't played drums in two years.
All right.
Okay.
I got married in the church and because my parents were members,
they couldn't go to the ceremony in the temple.
Okay.
What?
We did have a separate ring ceremony from my friends and family as a marriage in
the temple is usually small with a little pomp and circumstance.
Um,
I can't think of anything that I've heard that has hurt my parents as much as
this decision that I had made surrounding my beliefs.
The long talks,
the arguments,
the crying,
the pain of not around their son,
et cetera.
It was very hard on my family.
Through all of that though,
they want me to be happy and want me to be me.
We are closer now than we have ever been.
Having worked through our differences.
Your parents should always love and support you.
Well,
it depends on what you're doing.
Yeah.
You know,
if you're going to go rob a liquor store,
shoot some heroin.
I don't think they should love and support.
Well,
they could say no in a loving,
supporting way.
While I was at Byu,
there was a student in my program that took his life because he didn't like the
lifestyle of the church and was scared of what his parents would think.
Oh my God.
Haven't spoken to his parents after his death.
They would rather have this son alive and out of the church than dead and in the
church.
Wow.
It will be hard,
but don't ever feel like there is no way out and no way that,
and no one that has your back.
Byu can make you feel that way.
Begin to talk with your parents about it now and share how you feel about
yourself.
They will be hurt,
but still love you.
Eat a Dick Bill.
Get some meat on those bones.
You skinny bitch.
I love on a,
you know,
if I'm fat,
I'm fat.
If I'm skinny,
I'm too skinny.
I just can't make people happy.
Um,
all right.
What do we got here from a masculine lesbian lady?
Oh,
I put it out there.
You know,
Valentine's Day was coming up,
you know,
is coming up.
You need all the pressure is always on the guy.
And we have to show how much we loved them and they really don't have to do shit
other than put on something hot and bang you and they act like they're doing you
a favor when sex feels good to them too.
So I don't really don't understand,
you know?
Can you imagine if I acted like,
you know,
banging my wife was,
was this great pleasure thing for her as I'm on top of her,
like Ah,
ah,
like I'm not having a good time and those are the noises I make during sex and
you can fucking deal with that for the rest of the day.
Have that in your head.
Ah,
eh.
that's what I do on a loop,
on a loop.
Um,
from a masculine.
So I asked,
you know,
I want to talk to the man and the LED's them with a more manly woman in the
lesbian relationship.
Does what does she have to do?
Okay.
You know,
cause there's two ladies there right now.
Do you boat demand shit or does one,
you know the one who has to go up on the fucking roof during the rain to fix the
fucking,
you know,
Goddamn,
uh,
the,
the fucking satellite dish,
right?
So anyways,
hey yo.
Yeah,
I came Billy.
Okay.
Bib.
A city.
The bass city got another word.
I have to look up.
I have no idea.
Where do you guys,
where do you guys hear these fucking words?
I know I can't spell.
I know I'm fucking stupid
now.
[inaudible] usually
uncountable.
Uh,
the practice or habit of drinking too much alcohol.
Oh my God,
I love this word.
How do you pronounce it?
Pronunciation.
Is it the Basti
come on,
let me hear.
Let me hear it eventually.
Actually.
How do you say it?
The mastery as it a so you say bye bye.
[inaudible].
All right.
Ay Yo Billy.
Bob Asity.
Wow.
Visit this.
This,
this person's a Finca,
although I think you are back on the wagon of,
of late.
Yes,
I am.
Um,
I had been a fan of yours.
Wait,
am I going to look that word up again with Dai already?
Forget what it means.
Yeah.
Booze Hound,
right?
Hmm.
The Bass City,
the practice or habit of drinking too much alcohol.
Um,
somebody who Bose is,
that's a great name for a band.
It's a great name for a podcast.
Uh,
Billy verbosity,
I dunno if he can beat that.
That's a great wrestling character.
He's drunk.
He can't hear the ref.
Um,
I have been a fan of yours,
uh,
going on a decade now.
You are literally my favorite comedian all the way back to punching the muffins
in the,
at the flea market.
My flip and favorite.
Ah,
God bless you.
Uh,
you put out the call for a masculine lesbian the way to,
right.
So here's your ear full.
First off,
I have no idea what it's like to be a man.
All I know is that I can relate to so many of your jokes and rants about the
dynamics between men and women from the man's side.
Isn't it refreshing to hear a woman say she actually doesn't know what it's like
to be a man?
So many of these fucking assholes?
I know exactly what it's like.
It's easier.
Um,
I've,
you're,
you're a cartoon character.
I've been married to my lovely wife for 21 years.
The first nine illegally until same sex marriage became legal in Massachusetts.
Uh,
when we legalized our vows,
congratulations.
Uh,
in our relationship,
I am the breadwinner.
The fixer of are all broken things.
The killer of scary bugs for sure.
The one who would have to climb on the roof and fix the damn and 10 and the
rain.
Barring that,
the one that's got to negotiate with the servicemen,
while she nudges me and says,
just pay him,
I'm missing my show.
The one who pays for dinner,
even when I'm the,
the celebrated,
the list goes on.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
Could I have a beer with you further?
I am expected to ensure my lovely wife is wowed on Valentine's Day,
our anniversary and her birthday.
I make good money.
Don't get me wrong,
but my gosh,
I liked it.
You already said flipping in.
My Gosh.
Are you a card player?
The plague old lady cards.
Crazy eights.
Um,
what the hell am I?
I ended on,
my gosh,
I,
in fairness,
she puts up with my mercurial attitude,
circular debating and occasional raging,
wait,
if somebody trolling me right now,
is this the lesbian version of me still?
I have not,
but I don't say my gosh still,
I have no doubt that I would be cut in half
if we,
we divorced also,
no doubt she'll outlive me while being such a brave widow,
lol.
Uh,
before I get all Rodney Dangerfield on you,
no respect,
they'll tell you no respect at all.
Uh,
in truth,
we're the best of friends all the way back to our first day in high school.
She understands me more than anyone in my life and is truly help push me forward
in my career in ways I never thought possible when went.
See now as a man,
I don't think I could ever admit that about my wife.
Maybe that's the flaw.
Uh,
she's funny without trying and brilliantly smart and honest.
She helps me be a better person.
Wait,
did near right this and she's pretending to be a lesbian.
Um,
okay.
As a woman of a certain age,
49.
I came up at a time when dynamics between same sex relationship and had the male
female polarity exceed expectation attached.
I don't think it's as much that way now.
So much has changed in the Lgbtq culture since we were coming up.
Lesbian,
gay,
Bi,
trans,
queer.
I Fuck I can't,
it's something I'll say you have to look up.
I can never remember how that goes.
LGBTQ.
Um,
then back then
old man voice back in my day,
the term butch fem was hugely popular and I am definitely more butch.
It's also a regional identity associated more with the east coast and the West.
We've lived out west for over a decade and don't see a whole lot of butch.
Slash.
Femme.
Okay.
I Dunno,
but for that matter we're not nearly as social as we were back east.
So who knows?
You should totally do a study on butches.
We are,
we are a good lot.
Hope that helps and go fuck yourself to do you realize how fucking hilarious it
was.
It would be in a perfect world.
You went into a bar after having a fight with your wife and some
dude in the lesbian relationships,
sort of old school chick was sitting there at the bar and you both fucking hit
it off be fucking hilarious.
MMM,
I see.
I think that's just how it is.
I just think in maybe all relationships,
there's just,
there's the person that's fucking pulling the wagon and then there's a person
sitting in the wagon complaining.
Um,
you know,
but when you stop the,
they rub your back.
I don't,
I don't fucking know any dilemma,
dear Billy four in the road.
Is it supposed to be fork in the road?
That's for dear Billy.
For in the road.
If you had to choose between,
I think it's fork in the road.
If you had to choose between being president of the United States or pope of the
Catholic Church,
which would you choose and why?
Oh,
president.
Because I don't want,
it would have to make evil decisions for most eight years and at the least four
years.
That's why I would do it.
They're both absolutely horrific jobs and the amount of blood on your hands at
the end of it is,
um,
I don't think it's something you ever get past if you're a truly normal human
being.
And I don't,
but that's why I don't think normal human beings go for their job.
Go for those jobs.
All right.
Um,
and there's a lot of people,
you know,
especially in politics,
they put on the fucking white hat and they act like they're there for you.
Some of them are,
but they're always,
they're always now labeled as Socialists and working for,
you know,
isis or the Russians or whatever,
and they just get buried.
Um,
you know,
I dunno,
you watched,
you watched it,
that,
that young woman there,
that 29 year old woman who everybody is just flipping out about for whatever
reason,
because she's young and pretty.
I don't know why everybody's freaking out about her.
She has very little experience and everybody is freaking out.
Like,
she's fucking amazing me.
One of the things that she wanted to do was tax certain American 70% and it's
just like a taxing.
Anybody more than 50% is fucking criminal.
The fact that you're doing the job,
you actually get up and do the job and then somebody who didn't do the job gets
more fucking money then that is fucking criminal and watching this woman just
sitting there,
you know,
talking to these old politicians and acting like she's sitting there with the
two by four and it's going to start cleaning shit up and she's completely
ignoring the $800 billion gorilla in the room.
Completely fucking ignoring it.
Okay.
And she's gonna,
she w you watch all her righteousness and all her fucking bullshit.
I guarantee you.
Guess who's going to be a multimillionaire at the end of her political career,
even if she doesn't advance past the senator or House of representative level
where she only makes six figures a year guest who's going to be a
multimillionaire sign a massive book deal,
totally fucking sellout and buy a big ass fucking house and maybe doing an arena
tour like Michelle Obama or go on a speaking tour like every other fucking
president you watch and go,
they ain't going to talk to you.
They're going to out and talk to banks and corporations and everyone who finance
their fucking campaigns.
You fucking watch.
All right.
You saw what happened when Trump tried to pull the troops out of Syria.
Both Democrats and Republicans were 100% against that and they act like we can.
We can't display very displaced all these people but the,
but they don't give a fuck.
That's their money.
That money for being in that fucking bullshit over there.
That fucking shit right there is what makes them fucking millionaires,
multi,
multi fucking millionaires.
And all they do is sit there and blame each other and every mouth breathe and
fucking moron fucking just believes it,
drinks the Koolaid and then goes on Facebook and starts arguing with each other
and then starts advocating to tax a fellow American who didn't get us into those
wars upwards of 70 fucking percent.
That's the direction we're going to go in and it,
no,
and at no point are we ever going to examine the banking system or are we going
to look at corporations and see how they can be reeled back in to actually being
less powerful than the United States government or whatever country that they're
in.
All right.
That's the world you enter as president or pope.
Pope of the Catholic Church.
Catholic fucking church.
I mean,
I mean they're one of the biggest fucking terrorist organizations ever.
Ever.
The amount of fucking people that they tortured and murdered.
Yeah.
I mean they were in bed with the Nazis.
They were hiding one in the Nazis in their fucking churches.
One of the guys,
one of the fucking,
you know,
PR people,
part of the final solution that the,
uh,
whose side was hunting down was founded a fucking Catholic church in the south
of France.
Dead Jewish people's gold.
They had some of that in the church and they had the fucking give that bag.
I mean,
it's a fucking shit show.
Okay.
So if you get there,
that is a lifetime appointment.
And if you think you're going to go in there and change that when everybody else
in their previous to has all that blood on their hands,
like they're not going to view you as a threat.
Um,
yeah.
Those,
which was funny when Trump came in,
he's like,
I'm going to clean up the swamp.
Let's just say he actually did have a good heart and he wasn't like the fucking
Grinch.
Let's just say actually did have a good heart.
MMM.
That whole thing.
I'm going to clean up the swamp.
Like everybody there who was corrupt was going to be like,
well,
I guess the party's over.
He's going to clean it up.
No one's going to work with you.
No one's going to help you cut their own fucking head off.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I don't want to end on a depressing note,
but like that is,
it is a massive,
massive,
massive fucking
problem.
Um,
it's the reason why there's global warming.
It's the reason of overpopulation.
All of it goes back to corrupt politician in religion and that's as far as I can
tell and I'm not a smart guy.
You might know it better than me,
but there is no fucking reason why we shouldn't be polluting much less.
I was just reading something where like the continent of Africa is going to feel
the effects the first,
which is the worst fucking continent for that to happen too because with racism
and third boy people view so called Third World countries and everything,
nobody's going to give a fuck until it's in their fucking backyard and it's
going to be fucking too late.
So there you go.
There's one to grow on and that's why I fucking have gone back to reading
reader's digest,
looking at those dumb jokes,
just playing cards.
It's sitting on my back porch,
smoking a cigar,
staring at a fucking tree because
we're on a runaway fucking train and everybody and everybody who is a passenger
on the train is blaming everybody else on the other side of the aisle as if
they're the ones driving the fucking train.
Oh my God,
this is depressing.
Anyways,
that's the podcast.
God bless you.
It's almost baseball season.
Take me out to the ball game.
I just realized the volume was up super loud because I just took this mixer out
of my luggage.
I hope this wasn't too distorted.
Uh,
God bless you.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
You cuts.